the algs finals happened over the
weekend and what a ride it was a
full-time content creator almost winning
it all and the CEO Imperial how making
the comeback of a century to take it
home if you haven't been paying
attention listen up and listen well
[Music]
commenters I am feeling better so you
all can stop commenting about how I'm
not wearing makeup look hungover and or
exhausted and since you all did that
last time I think you all owe me a hit
of the like button the Subscribe button
and a ringing of the notification Bell
you know for emotional distress over the
weekend we saw the finals of the algs
year three and who howdy do we have
stuff to cover now I know we usually
don't cover the competitive Apex scene
on here and I'm admittedly pretty new to
the scene but let me tell you it was
insane and TSM we're gonna have to Point
these Watson fences could be massive
he plays folklore once again repeating
itself as hell again from the
with the Hostile takeover
oh your Champions
if you are new to the algs please grab a
c and your favorite drink and let me
tell you why you need to be watching
competitive Apex Legends to start what
you need to know is that defending
champs dark zero did not make it to the
finals this year so the crown was there
for everyone to take the CEO Imperial
Hal along with rapson verhulse brought
home the victory for TSM after a
stunning run that saw many jaws drop in
doubter silenced
TSM literally won the last two games to
bring themselves to match point and then
won the last one to win it all three in
a row the scriptwriters went out of
their way to give us an insane finale
Hell hath no fury like a TSM wanting a
championship I guess to put into
perspective how great this achievement
is optigaming had put themselves on
Match Point after game three they had
gotten half of the points needed just in
game one by the time TSM had match point
at game seven so did six other teams
including FaZe and dreamfire amongst
other Heavy Hitters Hal having been a
part of the TSM Apex team since 2019 saw
himself solidified as one of if not the
goat of a competitive Apex how is Apex
always has been always will be not only
did we see the CEO do well CEO things we
saw everyone's favorite content creator
it's Timmy make an incredible run ending
fourth overall with his team the dojo
not even the organization Timmy is
signed to 100 thieves made it to the
final stage and even they acknowledged
how incredible his run was you just
don't see this kind of thing for those
of us who don't know Timmy or just know
him from his streams you might not know
that he's competed in Apex before back
in 2019 he was signed to Golden
Guardians competing in Apex but they
didn't really see any noteworthy results
but with dojo this was Timmy's debut at
an international land and he looked
pretty damn good
it's our mirror though
in the Spitfire oh cause that charge
rifle it can be better used as a shotgun
but the dojo the dojo take thermal
I think that's enough Timmy you're not
bad
to make this even more impressive the
dojo made it to the land through a last
chance qualifier
we should have seen this coming Timmy
said I think our team will make finals
and not only that I expect at least a
top 10 finish from us and that is
exactly what they did literally to a t
it is hard to believe that Timmy
announced his return to competitive Apex
only a few months ago back in March and
that he was looking for a team and a
twit longer at the time Timmy explained
that his past competitive Apex
experience with golden Guardians and a
streamer team had left him disillusioned
and not wanting to compete anymore
saying that all the criticism impacted
his mental health in a negative way that
is completely understandable a person's
mental health is just as important as
their physical health Timmy found
himself on the receiving end of a
constant barrage of hate including in
Timmy's words things that weren't even
his fault that's gotta be taxing after
Timmy stopped competing he had
established himself as an excellent
content creator valorent Apex tarkov
pretty much everything he touched earned
him scores of new fans eventually Timmy
announced that he was competing as a
part of the dojo napex focused content
creation group that's been around since
2021. Timmy's team itself has seen its
fair share of changes with only Timmy
remaining from the original player
lineup what makes this even cooler is
the fact that the two people that ended
up playing finals with Timmy enemy and
design full had only joined in June
Timmy is one of the few if not only
content creators that has started
competing migrated to content creation
and then went back to competing
successfully now before I dodged
tomatoes to me is the only one that I
can think of right now but do you think
there's someone else that fits the bill
let me know down the comment section
below but the point is Timmy didn't have
to go back to competing he was doing
insanely well as a content creator he is
doing well but clearly he loves both
content and competing as Timmy wrote in
his twit longer I'm finally at a good
place in my life I'm ready to take on
competing once again and give it
everything I got yes I still will be
streaming and doing sponsors and Etc but
I will do my best to practice Grim
compete in tournaments learn grow and
improve as a player with my team I know
I'm washed right now but I will be back
in form for my community that who has
always supported me through my
competitive Endeavors thank you I will
not let you down this time tldr I'm back
[__] I think it is safe to
argue that Timmy did not let anyone down
a top four finish after qualifying
through the lcq and only competing for a
few months all of this while being a
full-time content creator and good news
for those of you who may have missed his
run he'll probably be back I think you
tweet to fans he assured them that next
time we will win it all I mean expect
the unexpected but next year looks
pretty promising maybe in year four of
the algs Timmy and the dojo can win it
all you can bet in year four that my
eyes are glued to the screen
and yours better be too
over the weekend we saw the finals of
the algs year three and who howdy
to make this
I swear to God can we stop with the air
horn out there please
I'm sure you're doing great work just
not now
they just did it right after I said that
you are bold sir